let's just take our first spin people oh
my god
whoa it's harvest season so this is a
blackhead cleaning camera from
asperex i've seen things like this all
over tik tok and instagram probably
advertised to me because
i click on things like this supposedly
it'll suck
all the juices out of the pores where
your blackheads are
in the box we have the vacuum slash
camera itself and
a number of different removable tips
that you can adjust the size
of the vacuum hole that sounds dirty
very excited i have plenty blackheads
right up here i like to say
that they're freckles just to make
myself feel better
my pores on my nose are like gaping at
this point it's
it's bad that's why today i'm using her
i am very afraid it kind of looks like
a baby bottle for space babies
how fancy it's like a little doctor's
office look at these little
section heads she's pretty this is
wild oh my god this is so gross
but so fascinating why does it look like
my skin is covered in plastic wrap
okay this is disgusting oh i have hairs
on my nose i'm literally so disgusted
with myself oh
wow there's some there's some stuff the
oils are definitely
oh look at the little worms coming up oh
yes i've never been that insecure about
my skin but now i'm looking closely at
it and i'm like i get it all out
get rid of it get rid of my skin i'm
just i'm too afraid to leave it on for
long enough for it to like
take anything out okay you want to try
it um yeah i do
okay let's just take her first spin
people
oh my god
whoa so clearly i am
yo it's harvest season oh
so disgusting i am gonna be looking like
a purple
peanut i feel like the places that i
have the most blackheads and whiteheads
are my nose
and like my chin i don't know what the
science is behind that i don't know if
your pores are bigger there i don't know
what goes on on
my face to be honest i'm just here to
suck it all out but it didn't feel that
strong when i put it against my finger
but when i touch it to my face it's like
wow is this a dyson
it's like plants growing in time lapse
harvest time oh man this is so
disgusting
i'm so self-conscious of this oh no oh
no
oh no
oh my god that's disgusting oh wait
that's not good
oops i did it again oh
no it's so red you were just a treasure
trove
oh thanks baby
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god you see that being dragged
[Music]
no the way that all of that just came
out of one tiny part of my nose is
alarming this is bruising my face damn
maybe i don't have blackheads maybe all
this is just little
nose hairs that i got going on here i'm
like what the hell
oh that was literally my lip
[Music]
oh no oh my god
that is so disgusting
okay i think we have to stop now because
this is what my nose is starting to look
like
there's one benefit to wearing masks all
the time these days
i get to cover all this up in public i
really want to try this on my boyfriend
i think he needs this if you have a
significant other
let them know that you're doing this
otherwise they're gonna like see all
these hickeys on your face
okay you keep saying they're hickeys but
like no one is gonna look at me
and see this and be like who have you
been hooking up with
quite an experience if i do say so
myself this thing
definitely works you just have to be
very careful with it use it
on the lowest setting at first and keep
moving across your skin
because if you stick in one place for
too long you end up with little hickeys
i don't know i don't think i would
recommend cause my face is
not looking good i did get some gross
chunks out though but like was it worth
it
[Music]